[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler
jean-pierre ont débuté et la république
en marche 5e circonscription du pas de
calais bonsoir jean pierre pont mercier
d'être avec nous à vos côtés stéphane
heures sénateurs reine des bouches du
rhône bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être sur notre antenne avant
évidemment d'entamer ce débat le chef de
l'état doit-il ou non s'excuser il a
déjà commencé ce soir avec ce tweet nous
n'oublierons aucun nom aucun visage
c'était les mots qu'il fallait selon
vous stéphane ravier mais justement nous
n'oublierons aucun moment n'ont aucun
visage ou un non plus le nom emmanuel
macron et l'ours élite du néolithique en
eux monsieur castex n'oublieront pas
l'exploit du nord sont responsables et
roule t il reconduit eu notre pays sont
attendus hier au père de plus de cent
mille deux cent mille morts
j'avoue apprendre que les nos
compatriotes qui sont immobilisés à leur
domicile ne sont même pas comptabilisés
dans celle de statistiques
et je pense aussi aux familles
témoignant de cet époux qui n'a pas pu
accompagner son épouse dans sa ep ligne
magnifique s'est ajoutée a les capacités
de 2 du gouvernement a à contrôler ce
que c'était fini donc des excuses
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais ça
changera rien dans la sphère le chef de
l'état et le gouvernant et paie l'impôt
gouverner c'est à dire pour prévoir il
en rien prévu et la catastrophe
sanitaire
je comprends certaines familles des
excuses moi j'attendais un désastre
sanitaire ou en finir avec cette
catastrophe et qui ne s'en produit ce
que d'autres
jean pierre papin sur ses premiers mots
tout d'abord qu'ils sont
peut-être le prémice effectivement comme
l'a promis le gouvernement d'un hommage
vous êtes en phase avec le chef de
l'état nous n'oublierons aucun nom aucun
visage ce sont les mots justes ce soir
oui je sens les mots justes je pense
qu'il faut penser bien sûr vers ceux qui
sont décédés mais aussi à leurs familles
familles qui n'ont pas pu tout à fait
faire leur deuil voir au dernier moment
leurs parents décédés mais vous pouvez
pas faire autrement
ce sont des personnes qui étaient
infectées donc le fait que d'autres
personnes puissent les accrocher sa cour
et décontaminer y avoir de répercussions
je pense aux mains jouées penser à ces
personnes décédées oui comme il faut
penser aussi aux soignants à tous ceux
qui les ont dû les accompagner même de
façon difficile mais je pense que tout
ce monde là et à mettre en avant
alors avant de vous faire répondre
stéphane ravier je voudrais vous faire
réagir aux propos d'olivier fort le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
qui a des mots durs envers l'exécutif
j'ai l'impression qu'emmanuel macro est
dans une forme d'insoutenables légèreté
c'est lui qui a laissé dire par ses
proches qu'il était devenu
épidémiologistes qui l'a laissé entendre
que la science était bien mais que la
politique devait prendre le dessus qu'il
était finalement celui qui savait mieux
que tout le monde
donc oui il a une responsabilité
particulière parce que c'est lui qui a
fait ses choix
c'est vrai que cette responsabilité
particulière même certaines associations
en parle 1 aujourd'hui disent en
substance il ne faut pas que le chef de
l'état s'excuse parce qu'il a eu une
partie des responsabilités aujourd'hui
clairement c'est votre propos stéphane
ravier serait ou doré une forme
d'indécence à ce que le chef de l'état
s'excuse et légère de l'état au final je
dirais que c'est bien normal c'est lui
qui a pris la décision le conseil
scientifique s'est prononcé il a émis
des avis et au final c'est le chef de
l'état qui a imposé à tous sa décision
ou ses décisions la réalité c'est que
fois ils étaient en retard ou alors ils
se trompent et cc c'est la réalité il
s'est trompé en refusant de fermer les
frontières lorsque vous le demande du
nous le demandions pardon nous dès le
mois de mars l'année dernière il s'est
trompé à la mort lorsqu'il a participé
lui aussi à ne pas ré équiper l'hôpital
commune aurait dû l'être
il s'est trompé en n'ayant pas commandé
les mages qui s'est trompé en eux
commandant pas à les respirateurs s'est
trompé dans la commande des vaccins
lorsqu'ils à idéologiquement lorsqu'il
s'est mis à la revente que de l'union
européenne qui a été un frein à la
commande de ces vaccins et donc à la
vaccination mais qu'il se soit trompé
swype est en retard de bout en bout
il porte donc l'entière responsabilité
de cette gestion entre guillemets de
cette crise interne du genou je
n'imagine pas démissionner avant les
élections présidentielles mais c'est aux
français à se souvenir que celui qui
aurait dû anticiper celui qui aurait dû
protéger et bien à laisser le peuple
français
être le plus exposé quasiment d'europe
et même au delà quand on sait
qu'aujourd'hui en france il ya 15 % de
matinée contre 37% au chili alors je
n'ai aucun mépris pour les chiliens bien
sûr mais quand on on dit que la france
est un pays est l'un des pays les plus
avancés du monde et on est loin derrière
le chili c'est qu'il ya bien un problème
local un problème structurel dans le
chef de l'état porte une lourde
responsabilité
jean pierre pont c'est vrai que ça
revient souvent évidemment les critiques
vous l'ignorez pas on en parle tous les
jours partout sur la gestion de la crise
personne n'a dit évidemment que ces
manuels mâcon qui a porté le coup vide
mais beaucoup critiquent et fustigé
durement la gestion de la crise
sanitaire du gouvernement que
pouvez-vous répondre votre adversaire ce
soir quand il ne fait part de ses
critiques
objectif tout de même mais de toute
façon la piaule gouvernement était
depuis le début critiquer ça a été avec
les mâles ce que le confinement la
sortie du confinement
les vaccins ces terrasses a toujours été
ne critique mais aucune opposition de
l'opposition faut pas oublier que cette
maladie ou la connaissez pas on ne
savait pas comment elle allait évoluer
alors prévoir quand on connaît mal
d'autant plus que je suis médecin moi
que tous venir en décembre 2019
quand on a commencé à parler du corry je
lui dis pas ça va être que vous créez et
puis l'on bat je me suis trompé
elle peut être beaucoup plus douce et 2
par rapport à ce qui était annoncé ce
qui a été vu au moins parra au début
c'était de essayer de de contrecarrer
l'évolution de ce virus et je suis sûr
que ya six mois on ne pouvait pas
imaginer cette deuxième phase et
pansements qui a ce virus brésilien
tente d'émerger et je pense qu'il est
facile de dire y'a qu'à faut qu'on
un mais deux banques encore une fois la
maladie était totalement
on ne connaissait pas son évolution on
connaissait pas comment la traiter et on
en a entendu des traitements aussi de
droite et de gauche mais je pense que le
gouvernement a fait au mieux au mieux
par rapport à ce qui lui est arrivé et
il est facile de dire bah oui il fallait
prévoir mais je pense que prévoir devant
cette maladie
c'était quasiment impossible il a juré
suivant le conseil scientifique
et pourtant lors dans l'hémicycle
j'ai entendu des critiques par rapport
au conseil scientifique en disant ben
oui c'est lui qui dirige la france alors
que le conseil scientifique et de là
pour éclairer et de politiques pour
décider et e
quand on regarde le nombre d'avis qui
peut y avoir les temps médecins sont
entendus de tout de tout y est
du grand du moins deux pour du concours
de confrères et même quelque chose d
fois absolument effarant n'oubliez pas
qu'au début de l'épidémie où elle me
disait que les masques n'était pas
nécessaire
au tout début alors donc on peut aussi
critiquer l'om est ce qu'elle se soit
trompé mais je pense que le gouvernement
a géré au mieux en fonction de ce qu'il
savait et par rapport aux 6 à la tante
de la population parce qu'il ya le
contexte sanitaire il a ajouté que ce
économique des camarades y est c'est
intéressant je me dis monsieur pons
parce que on dit il a voulu faire trop
de politique mais il a aussi peut-être
essayer de préserver l'économie jusqu'au
bout c'est ce que souhaitait aussi une
partie des français
ce que dit le député du nord la santé
qu'elle est critiquée à l'extériorité du
pas-de-calais
ne m'en voulez pas pour ça ça reste la
france ne sont pas contenté de critiquer
a posteriori et le mois de mars nous
avons proposé de fermer les frontières
juste quand on ne sait pas et que l'on
annonce une telle gravité comme la
cimade l'usaid et le froid de janvier
eh bien on prend des précautions on
ferme les frontières
ce n'est un nouveau succès nos fansites
mesures de protection qui concerne tous
ceux qui sont sur le territoire français
comme les autres
vous avez refusé nous avons demandé
l'achat massif de massy plus une
campagne sanitaire se ferait pas on
dirait des années un en-avant maman vous
nous sommes nous avons toujours proposé
une réindustrialisation
notre piste nous aurait permis de
produire des masques nous avons toujours
dénoncé les coupes sombres fait à
l'hôpital et les terriens matière de
vaccins encore récemment le président de
la république a choisi de refuser le
vaccin russe alors qu'il a montré toute
son efficacité il s'agit donc là d'un
choix idéologique qui prive les français
de nombreux de nombreuses doses de
vaccin et on ne peut pas dire que le
prison le président ne sais pas c'est un
choix purement idéologique qui met en
danger nos compatriotes et qui continue
le mettre en danger notre économie aussi
parce que au plus sombre du motard et
bien la maladie le virus continue à se
développer et se sont aussi c'est aussi
le monde économique qui en souffrent
puisque depuis plusieurs mois les
commerçants à nouveau les bars les
restaurants depuis bientôt six mois sont
fermés ils sont jeunes éléments arrivent
bientôt à la fin de ce débat on a
compris votre idée stéphane ravier bien
sûr jean pierre pont quand on entend
stéphane ravier nous dire où il a refusé
pour l'instant c'est pas un vrai revue
enfin on sent qu'il n'est pas aidé par
enthousiaste par rapport aux italiens
aux allemands ils voient là il est en
train de tendre les bras aux vaccins
russe faut bien le dire on a entendu
thierry breton clément bonneu l'iran ne
rassemble pas besoin bon ça en tant que
médecin c'est important vous êtes député
la république en marche mais vous êtes
aussi médecin on a entendu beaucoup de
médecins sur ce plateau nos liens voilà
il faut prendre ton ce combat et on ce
qui marche
oui mais qu'est ce qui marche c'est à
dire que iliad est comment dire des
normes européennes a regardé franchi si
on lui difficile qui a des poubelles
comme c'est par lui comme une certaine
action on nous vous prouvera je pense
qu'il ya actuellement des normes
il faut les respecter c'est vrai
qu'elles sont un peu lentes et joue mais
je pense que c'est d'un système
que nous avons est qu'il faut le
respecter moi personnellement j'ai passé
quatre week-ends à vacciner dix n'ont
pas de calais et personnellement dans ma
patientèle genre et à une centaine de
vaccins très bien actuellement tout à
fait alors merci jean pierre point
d'avoir été avec nous en tout cas
d'avoir accepté ce débat merci à vous
également stéphane ravier